mon dieu c'est nul c'est quoi la vie
risque ont laissé moi c'est moi ou c'est
moi toi
français qui mazet c'est le rap français
de rap français qui vous les i il ya
beaucoup de passion qui sont
transparents film en salle et le voyez
il ya les guerriers il ya des cheveux
détachés
cette ceinture c'est pour votre sécurité
le soir sur 27 ans fermé
c'est l'autre limite je sais
le monde des livres
dieu merci maintenant les oublis 17,2
[Musique]
pour brut j'ai passé plusieurs jours en
immersion dans les services
psychiatriques de seine-saint-denis qui
font face à une nouvelle vague de
patients directement lié à la crise du
colis de 19 avec le docteur mouaffaq et
ses équipes
vous allez découvrir le quotidien de
celles et ceux qui accompagnent les
patients victimes de maladies mentales
[Musique]
important
passons présentons les premiers épisodes
psychotiques
simon
il semble
bondy fait
autres qui sont persuadés
nue circulent sur nous
je suis
viennent nous dire qu'ils sont à
l'origine
vingt joueurs de faire leur
[Musique]
cya
petit
calais n'est pas du tout la guerre
confinement et du malade
suite du coup monsieur qui arrivait hier
soir dorion il est toujours dans une
délire mystique avec le fait que ce soit
la fin du monde et que tu as lu thi
c'est ça
c est ma clé du jugement dernier
et que du coup l'empêcher de mener à
bien sa mission et c'est pas cette
vision là bas du coup c'était sous
vêtements cette passion
hélas
c'était 31 août en 2d comptant sur le
plan de la douche ce qui s'est bien
passé même si c'est très organisé
à midi j'étais vivante dans l'europe via
des messages qui lui étaient destinés à
lui directement
donc il ya une mission à savoir faire
que tout le monde
on dit
fico est longtemps passée on ne peut pas
le des conventionnels durable on puisse
lui il a des états d'agitation et qu'il
se fait mal autres ils sont en danger en
cassant la porte
voilà vraiment il est difficilement
accessible à l'assurance
bonjour je suis un homme sur moissac
quand ça va rires ça a été un peu
compliqué non
et c'est
j'avais mal entrer d'autres propos qui
ont pu quitter sans histoires de
c'était mon dieu c'est sérieux c'est une
foire l'inversé moi c'est moi tous ces
mois ouais
français france c'est le français qui
toutes ces idées là ce sont des idées
qui viennent de laisser qu'il vous
faudrait
c'est plus vous laissons tomber comme
s'il était comme si ce n'est en bas
s'ils étaient de l'autre
ils vous envoient les
c'est ici j'ai
il s'agissait manifestement c'est moi la
france c'est toi qui m'as sauvé la terre
ce qu'ils font c'est faux vous avez ces
comportements qui vous fait vous vous
risquez de vous casser ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas une punition c'est juste jet
ski
mais c'est mon jeu
[Musique]
elle est revenue à la hausse
c'est
c'est normal
restait à six qu'elle tombait pour
l'égalisation
[Musique]
fessé chute du premier étage
vous êtes tombés points
je pense en jeu
non
les choses iront mieux pour roy prend ce
qui s'est passé c'est que souvent on
oh
ses mobiles
g
samson
c
oh
c'est justement sur des profils dugongs
fragilité se passer comme d'autres
passent et le confinement a certainement
jouer un paul célébrations qui se sont
retrouvés
quand il est limité dans leur mouvement
alors que hoarau
il arrivait à s'équilibrer disant haut
niveau lui à l'extérieur quand la cité
oua mais ont une petite activité
les structures et des fous
bouleversée
la maladie mentale est un sujet
difficile à aborder et c'est aussi très
difficile d'interroger des patients qui
sont en grande détresse psychologique
j'ai quand même pu m'entretenir avec
ceux qui sont hospitalisés dans
l'établissement le docteur mouaffaq ils
m'ont parlé de leur traitement souvent
lourd mais aussi de leur enfermement le
quartier il ya les cheveux détachés
vous savez si vous savez
à 15 ans est refermé attendant elle pas
dans le coma du poignet on a de quoi
être fier
ces deux semaines comment se sent bien
que c'est bien
c'est bien c'est bien qu'ici enfin on
veut juste et bien mais si tu fais le
pari la rossa sais quoi dans la vie
oui c'est pas ça se prolonge
moi
oh
pourquoi tu es ici si la chute des
banques affaiblies sur youtube
et c'est comme un dentiste c'est plus la
rémission chez le ch sur son programme
est ce que tu trouves cette détresse ou
non ces mauvais l'émission il faut des
âmes
chez moi
magique
d'ailleurs mme michaud
oui oui tout changer en faire quoi
je te prends pas
il dormira journée s'écoule à balayer
tout juste cherché à mâcher ses mots
[Musique]
gennady mentale et quelque chose
d'insaisissable on a toujours peur de ce
qu'on ignore ça devrait être logique
si on perd est cuit à part
conquis
jusqu'à 0
un genou tu noteras il raconte à ce plus
faibles sont vitales toujours essayé
doit trouver un équilibre c'est
fatigué que les parents les tableaux
banier falloir les habitués à la vie
locale
la seo
en seine saint denis comme dans beaucoup
d'autres endroits en france les salles
et psychiatriques sont débordés et ça
fait des années que ça dure
mais avec la crainte du virus et toutes
les contraintes qui vont avec leur
mission est devenu quasiment impossible
c'est simple il n'ya clairement plus à
cette place pour recevoir tous les
malades dans de bonnes conditions
[Musique]
voilà
voilà tu sais
depuis quand même pas vous êtes là
j'attends qu'on me dise
mais moi si vous êtes vous ici
vous êtes vous
vous êtes à l'hôpital
weedon
oui
vous avez de la famille des proches
départ et ça
g
oui personne ne veut le fondre est ce
facile aux urgences mans il faut
absolument qu'on puisse régler cette
situation
tentative d'homicide
ils ont fait sortir je crois il est
revenu
mais ça c'est le mystère des
organisations sa joie quand j'ai entendu
ça je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je
voulais merci
pourquoi tous les risques
ma
c'est
c'est énorme
en moyenne on a cette huile passion mon
âme
sk temps
la vague on en a compté trois fois plus
que plus sont la vrille 2010
il faut aussi que ça arrive
mais l'autre limite c'est
le monde de vifs
mon lit a posé le fond filmant sa en
attendait avant de
roux souci je vivrai je vais aller et il
nous parle
qu'est ce que vous faites bien attention
qui arrive qui vous n'êtes pas
disponible il souffrait
on est obligé de solliciter d'abord on
en met la pression au service
c'est le ceo parce qu'on les appelle en
départ et ça fait des conflits
soral et il ya les infirmiers les gars
se transforme
de ces deux instituts colonisation
galopante on
la jetta il gèle donc il faut passer
plusieurs heures à essayer du coût des
solutions essayer de créer des lits qui
n'existera alité et c'est vraiment
frustrant ce renoncement sous etc
sophie correctement ça va passer
conditions dignes il est à l'annoncé
deux volets les doses nécessaires ont
pas d'appliquer des stratégies
qu'ils sont censés juste veiller aux
défauts de livres
famous à ses fans des fois mon 2 août
au bout de temps
on peut tout voir
bonjour bonjour je suis absolument pas
ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé
je suis sans doute
il se fonde l empire il n'y avait là bas
tu en battant comme ça sur le carrelage
110 et un ballon aux six mètres et ont
déjà cassé ma pote nous lisent les
policiers vont casser l'accord entre ses
conceptions javan touria pas toujours
bien contre ça moi je suis allé à
l'église et allumé des cierges et prié
je crois pas qu'ils soient toujours cd
soit toujours les mains c'est une
passion
créée
au nom de
c'est étriqué à vous joindre
des infirmiers diront certains
[Musique]